I'm disgusted by the new Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and it's not that no and
not just disgusted by their creepy
all-too-human CG faces why would you
deliberately plumb new depths of uncanny
valley mess I mean their heads look like
me if my nose was sanded off no wonder
megan fox faints at the sight of them
no I'm disgusted by the new turtle fling
because it's completely unnecessary the
1990 film version with mobile and
expressive animatronics courtesy of Jim
Henson's Creature Shop was way better
than had any right to be yeah the new
movie didn't have those nightmarish
heads the chance and it'll improve on
the 1990 film our slim why is everyone
rushing to remake classic movies see for
every terrific remake every Phil
Kaufman's body-snatchers or John
Carpenter's thing or Cronenberg's fly
there are a hundred subpar remakes that
never justify their right to exist some
of them are so underwhelming that they
erode the reputation of the original and
Robocop remake I am speaking to you the
hell did you do to me huh don't try to
duck behind that awful roller ball
remake and these recent releases are
just the tip of the iceberg I mean what
possible good can come of this
hey Hollywood instead why not spend
hundreds of millions on remaking the
movies so you can actually improve upon
movies that had can't fail premises yet
still managed to fail I wholeheartedly
endorse the planned remakes of film such
as flight of the navigator black hole
Green Lantern van Helsing Fantastic Four
Green Lantern Logan's Run Jumanji Green
Lantern drop dead Fred Green Lantern and
Green Lantern
all right hey if you're taking remake
recommendations the preteen space travel
flick explorers top of my list the
original had no right to be so
underwhelming oh and I'd love to see a
good version of trances Mickey Rourke
was born to play Jack deth orgies maybe
you could go back and make a good
version of let's be cops my bad I know I
know the original hasn't come out yet
but the trailer looks terrible what's
your least favorite remake see I'm torn
between the 1998 psycho and the 2006
wicker man unless Thunderbirds counts
yeah let me know your picks in the
comments and subscribe to the wired
Channel